[موسيقى]
عندما أحبك أشعر بالهدوء
أقول لكم جميع الطاقة المبهم سول سول
الطاقة الراكدة وأنا
هدئ أعصابي وأشعر أنني بحالة جيدة اسمي
هذا هو دومينيك كيلر شفايتسر أنا
أنا معروف كفنان باسم
ادم حياكة انا طبيب دكتور
طبيب نفساني ومهنتي الثانوية
لنفترض أنها حياكة صنعتها
ادمج كل شيء وأنا أصنعه
حياكة الطب النفسي يحاول ذلك أنا
اكتشف الحياكة أو الكلمة والاطفال
حوالي سن 7-8 سنوات أعطاني إياها جدتي
تعلمت ربط الأساسيات
طوال حياتي لقد حبكت لكني فعلت
شاي كلاسيكي متماسك
الشالات والسترات الأشياء
من هذا القبيل حتى عام 2011 عندما كنت
فجأة قررت أن تجعل
الأشياء ثلاثية الأبعاد الأول
الشيء الذي حبكته كان a
سمك
أريتها حذر بلدي الأسماك ولها
قل لي ولكن الآن ترى أنك
أجعل دجاجة الكذب جيدة أنا
سأصنع دجاجة وواصلت ذلك
يمارس الطب النفسي منذ عام 2001
قبل أن أصبح ممارسًا عامًا وأنا
متخصص في طب الرضوح
هذا عندما أدركت ذلك
يمكن أن تساعد الحياكة في
الطب النفسي
لأنه عندما تعرضنا لصدمة
افصل جزأين من
الدماغ وإعادة الاتصال
يتطلب حركات متكررة من
الجانبين للتنسيق
مع الحياكة لديك إبرتان
وأنت تفعل الشيء نفسه دائمًا
حركة متكررة وتشبهها
إذا قمت بإزالة الجانب بينهما
نصفي الكرة الأرضية
وهي فعالة جدا في العلاج
صدمة
[موسيقى]
لقد حصدت بالفعل كل ما قمت بحياكته
متجر الجزارة متجر لبيع المعجنات
مصنع الجبن أنا متماسكة الرؤوس
الأجزاء التشريحية البشرية في
الفائز بقلب كان
صحيح تشريحيا في سويسرا أنا
في المتحف حيث تركت المواهب توماس
زيورخ
هذين المتحفين للفن الحديث و
تقنية وتصميم حيث لدي ثلاجة
مليئة بالطعام خاصة
لحم الخنزير واللحوم الدقيقة و
أشياء جميلة النقانق الأرز
شاهد
بشكل عام ردود الفعل جدا
الأشخاص الإيجابيون يبتسمون غامضة
دعابة أقول ولكن لماذا أفعل هذا
الجواب لأنه يجعلني
بكل سرور
يعجبني أنا أحبه
[موسيقى]